[Musica]
questo sono io quando ero piccola era
una bambina molto buona ma anche molto
movimentata e amavo tantissimo i miei
genitori e mio papà e lui era soggetto
trasferimento perché faceva il
pubblicitario
infatti ho frequentato le scuole
elementari ogni anno in una città
diversa
sono figlia unica però un giorno ha
deciso di farla finita per via delle
estorsioni
il pizzo ed eravamo proprio qui a
catania
da lui ho ereditato la mente
imprenditoriale perché io sono la mamma
di toki un ragazzone loro diverso
speciale lui è autistico psicotico
l'iperattivo o positivo
a vent'anni e fin da piccolino è stato
speciale ce ne siamo accorti a due anni
e mezzo e per lui oggi io vi racconterò
perché sto costruendo insieme alla mia
famiglia
la casa di toti che lei la mia mamma da
lei ho ereditato la positività
l'emozione inevitabile
le mie passioni
il mare la pesca e la moto ho avuto la
prima moto quando avevo nove anni non lo
potevo neanche portarla arrivavo al
cancello di casa e poi ho avuto una moto
da enduro a 16 anni cielo tuttora è oggi
la guida toti perché insieme a mio
marito
noi abbiamo subito dato la possibilità a
tutti di fare tutto questo sono io in
ufficio e lavoro in un'azienda
farmaceutica da 28 anni è la mia seconda
casa per scelta lavoro solo la mattina
per dedicarmi appunto la famiglia e in
questa azienda sanno cosa vuol dire
essere la mamma di topi e in tutte le
aziende dovrebbero abbracciare le
famiglie speciali il mio grande amore
mio marito michele l'ho conosciuto nel
1988 e siamo ancora insieme anche se a
volte quando dico mi è venuta un'idea un
po paura che lui ma lui è sempre accanto
a me e mi supporta e mi sopporta i miei
meravigliosi figli
io non sono solo la mamma di topi ma
sono anche la mamma li felice lui a 17
anni è un sibling un fratello speciale e
adesso qui mette un punto perché io non
voglio parlare di lui ma io sono
convinta che un domani lui mi dirà
grazie mamma grazie papà perché avete
creato la casa di toti
eccola la mia famiglia e siamo proprio
in un campo a modica perché io sono
modicana catanese di adozione papa e
milanese per questo un po questa cadenza
e molti me lo chiedono e qui è proprio
quando abbiamo deciso insieme di fondare
una onlus e di creare la casa di tokyo
il primo albergo solidale in sicilia un
albergo che sarà gestito da ragazzi
speciali 7 dai 18 ai 25 anni dove loro
potranno vivere in cohousing e dove loro
potranno lavorare perché dopo la scuola
c'è il nulla
molti di loro potrebbero frequentare
l'università ne sono convinta e questa
sarà la mia prossima lotta perché io le
università non l'ho potuto frequentare
perché ho dovuto lavorare le estorsioni
di mio padre hanno lasciato veramente
tanti debiti perché alle banche non
gliene frega niente se devi dare dei
soldi e mi sono rimboccata le maniche
eccolo lui è felice è quella la mia
vespa
toti da piccolo durante la notte prima
che assumesse tutti i suoi psicofarmaci
ahimé entrava in camera di notte diceva
è adesso uno bello cartone e tutti
guardavamo uno bello cartone ma dopo un
po
avevamo anche noi bisogno di ricaricare
le batterie oppure da quando come mi
chiamavano da scuole dicevano vieni
subito toti ha fatto quello fatto
l'altro
e allora siamo arrivati neuropsichiatria
dove hanno iniziato a calmarlo con gli
psicofarmaci ma lui è un farmaco
sensibile è un farmaco resistente e
quindi di psicofarmaci ne ha cambiati
tanti di centri di eccellenza ne abbiamo
girati tanti da vicino nessuno è normale
lui stesso una volta me lo ha detto a
volte me lo ripete perché totti parla
grazie alla tanta logopedia
psicomotricità mamma io non mi posso
sposare perché ho paura di avere un
figlio come me
perché lui c'è la sua mini moto una
delle tante moto però se totti al bianco
vuole il nero ultimamente abbiamo
comprato un motociclo e adesso vuole
un'altra moto e ovviamente tu mamma
speciale to famiglia può interpretare
anche questi queste richieste come
capricci ma loro sono speciali e devi
entrare nel loro mondo in punta di piedi
i suoi disegni alcuni anche un po
inquietanti ma quello al centro per me è
il più importante perché la casa di
totila disegnata lui anche se vedete
l'etna alle spalle perché noi abitiamo
in un paesino qui vicino a catania è
sempre tanti colori come questa mamma
che ama i colori la zia margherita la
sorella di mio marito
per me e mia sorella perché appunto
siamo cresciute insieme mio nipote
gianluca e la passione che abbiamo per
gli animali che abbiamo trasmesso anche
i nostri figli
il nostro piccolo labrador oggi ne
abbiamo due costruirò la casa di tokyo
sì questo è il primo articolo in basso
vedete ali e ibrahim perché noi per
gestire toti in famiglia abbiamo bisogno
di aiuti 24 ore su 24
oggi non c'è questa copertura in questo
momento il pomeriggio non ho nessuno ma
ce la farò perché la gente purtroppo non
riesce a gestire tanta iperattività
ibrahim oggi e in germania è stato con
noi un anno
ali oggi a casa con toti lui lavora per
un'industria qui a catania è stato con
me un anno ma quando ho bisogno li corre
perché questi ragazzi che vengono
dall'africa sanno cos'è la puzza della
vita e toti ha insegnato tanto alloro
eccola qui vedete la villa del 700 che
abbiamo deciso di reggio rigenerare in
un hotel un hotel solidale etico
significa un hotel aperto alla gente dal
cuore grande
significa che se tu vuoi venire a modica
trascorrere due giorni
lo potrei fare e sarai assistito da
questi ragazzi che faranno il check in e
check out la pulizia delle camere e la
pulizia del giardino si prepareranno la
colazione ma tutto questo lo faranno in
cohousing perché quello che stiamo
costruendo è una casa priva di barriere
architettoniche dove loro potranno
vivere e lavorare con l'assistenza dei
tutor
quindi noi stiamo costruendo un durante
noi genitori speciali un dopo di noi è
un impresa nel sociale lui a franco
antonello e andrea siamo molto amici di
un giorno gli telefonai non un giorno
gli telefonai tante volte perché non mi
rispondeva mai ma io quando voglio una
cosa insisto un giorno mi ha risposto e
sono entrata a far parte della sua
diciamo organizzazione fondazione perché
lui mi ha insegnato a fare found raising
crowdfounding abbiamo reclutato in tre
anni 21 aziende che ci sostengono
ma non con una offerta una donazione
perché noi non abbiamo bisogno di
offerte spot ma abbiamo bisogno di
continuità per creare un'opera sociale
come quella che stiamo costruendo e oggi
ho accanto 21 aziendale vorrei citare
una per una
no lo dico ma loro sono sempre accanto
ogni mese con una buona cifra e in più
abbiamo 100 doratori privati abbiamo il
found raising abbiamo il 5 per mille io
neanche sapevo cosa significasse
crowdfounding oggi mi reputo un esperta
di fund raising crowdfunding perché io e
mio marito abbiamo fatto tutto da soli e
continueremo a farlo perché la casa di
tokyo sta per essere inaugurata noi ci
auguriamo la prossima primavera ma poi
dovrà andare avanti e stiamo lavorando
tanto nella gestione abbiamo creato una
grande squadra il mio libro nel 2016 ho
deciso di buttar giù di fare un po di
outing
ho scritto il libro calle calle
biografia di un sogno perché calle calle
e l'urlo che grida toti quando è
contento lui mette una mano così
kalle calle ecco un po di escursus di ai
lavori di casa di toti la concessione
edilizia perché la casa di toti nasce su
300 metri quadri in un campo di calcetto
in disuso il calcio la passione di mio
padre
la villa l'unico riferimento che io ho
avuto come causa perché ne ho cambiate
tante quindi la cassaforte della mia
vita
il tetto di vetro che vedrete che la
stanno per montare perché io nel mio
sogno ho visto i miei ragazzi che
guardavano in alto attraverso un tetto
di vetro perché loro non possono sempre
stare chiusi a casa perché loro non
possono fare solo giochi al tavolo o
come dice una mia amica infilare le
perline o cantare al karaoke loro
possono fare loro devono lavorare devono
essere impegnati con una giusta
assistenza
questa è una delle ultime foto la
piscina già c'era a casa molti magari
hanno pensato penseranno adesso questi
quasi stanno ristrutturando la villa no
noi abbiamo donato il terreno ci siamo
spogliati di parte di una villa e vero
che io l'ho rigenerata così come io
volevo perché io avrei voluto studiare
economia e turismo a milano avrei voluto
creare un hotel
lo sto creando ugualmente avrei voluto
dormire sempre in questa stanza questa è
la mia camera ma la sto donando perché
sarà la suite dell'hotel solidale cose
brutte bowyer rete potrete essere
accolti dai miei ragazzi in queste
camere tanti premi fin dall'inizio fin
dal sogno dal 2014 all inizio ero anche
un po turbata dicono cosa sto facendo ma
non mi bastava toti adesso dovrò pensare
a 7 toti ma oggi ne sono fiera
anche perché ripeto c'è una grande
squadra c'è uno studio di psicopedagogia
che sta selezionando i ragazzi le
famiglie sempre accanto e gli operatori
fantastici anche jovanotti accanto
quindi gente del mondo dello spettacolo
io credo molto nella visibilità non
perché mi piace mettermi in vetrina
è bello ma questo ci ha aiutato tanto e
tu si che vale sono arrivata lì per caso
avevano preso me e io ho detto no io non
vengo se non vengono anche i miei
ragazzi sono stati su quel palco che ci
ha dato veramente tanta visibilità con
le magliette disegnate da toti siamo
riusciti a venderne e tantissime la
barca io e mio marito abbiamo pensato di
chiedere in affido una barca confiscata
all'immigrazione una barca etica che noi
mettiamo a disposizione di tutte le
associazioni e presto faremo un giro in
tutta la sicilia perché io voglio
portare il messaggio di casa di toti
vorrei che i genitori potessero pensare
che qualcosa si può fare non essere
sempre critici contro chi non fa il
governo le istituzioni
rimbocchiamoci le maniche se noi
possiamo io avevo una casa e la sto
trasformando in un hotel ma a chi ha un
panificio può fare anche un'impresa
sociale mettere la cassa a suo figlio i
miei ragazzi gli operatori sono tanti
non so chi entrerà a far parte della
casa di toti ma io voglio che questa
idea sia contagiosa perché di case di
toti ne dovrebbero nascere tante lui
toti ispirazione di tutto e adesso
grazie e calle calle
[Applauso]
[Musica]